foreign
episode as always it's just my honor and
pleasure to continue to host these
conversations and we do like to change
things up a little bit in terms of the
topics that we talk about so today we
want to bring in a conversation about
immigration culture faith and mental
health and so today I'm honored to be
able to welcome you Jay Harris to the
ADI Hour podcast I'm going to give him a
little bit of introduction so you all
know a little bit about him some of you
may be familiar with him from his book
which would be outstanding for those who
aren't UJ Harris is a passionate fan of
mental and emotional health and how it
intersects with faith he is the
president of psychology for all which is
a Charlotte North Carolina based
non-profit that works to drive Mental
Health Care equity and access for
under-resourced people he's a father an
encourager and a contributing author to
the book Liberia's son which captures
the story of his family's resilient
Journey from a Civil War in Liberia it's
navigating opportunities and challenges
and life in the U.S so I know that's
something that will unpack as we go
through the conversation today but again
just want to welcome you Jay to the
program here today thanks for being here
EJ
thank you so much for having me I'm
super proud to to be part of this
opportunity thanks so much and this has
been this has been a long time coming in
a lot of different ways so yeah good to
see it come to fruition
um I should mention even though it pains
me as a Duke graduate to mention that
you got an MBA from UNC Chapel Hill that
is part of your path and I know you have
a ba inside I'll see you on Saturday man
we'll see you on Saturday
oh my goodness I also gotta give a shout
out to to my to Davidson Wildcats I'm
gonna dance Brad as well had some love
for those people yeah excellent
excellent thank you forever I'm going to
hang out at Davidson to the folks who
ever let me in there but I think that
was a that was a good call on their part
um so obviously you know people have
heard a little bit about you in that
introduction and will definitely jump
into that as a conversation unfolds but
as you know as my listeners know I do
always like to check in and just see how
how our guests are doing at this point
in time so you know we're finishing up
February entering March of 2023 and just
wanted to ask how you're doing at this
point in time uh life-wise and just with
everything we're navigating as a society
yeah that's a great question you know
and it's sort of like how are you really
doing right this is not the uh just give
me the friendly answer and things are
actually going pretty well the last
couple years as you can imagine we're
pretty interesting a lot of adjustments
you know with uh with with the pandemic
but things are settling well and uh I'm
doing well I feel I feel like under life
is pretty stable uh I'm gonna say drama
free so you know it's a it's a a joke
and they say it's it's good to be UJ
right now I don't think for that so for
asking brother that's good to hear yeah
especially as you know you've mentioned
just the the honesty of you know having
to navigate through different things one
thing I didn't mention for our listeners
too I mean you have the psychology for
all organization but then you're also
the vice president of a customer and
market research consultancy so how how
is that journey in terms of navigating
and I don't know if balancing is the
right word I usually use the word
juggling but how is that aspect of your
life at this point in time yeah you know
it's interesting people think because I
talk about my non-profit so much I think
that there are people who know me and
think that I actually that's my
full-time job and because it is a
passion of mine um it went from
something that I was doing as a
volunteer to announcement that I see
more as a as a real necessity in some
way almost as a Ministry you know to use
of a term
um but it's it's great I I in my
corporate job sort of gives me it allows
me to sort of plow my skills as a
marketer and and someone who likes to
solve business problems and and then
sort of manage relationships you know in
terms of clients and then the non-profit
really allows me to do something that is
more of a passion that that I think
truly makes really a real difference in
people's lives and so it's a good
balance you know some people who say Hey
you know why can't you just find
something that allows you to do both
well if you can great but uh you know
it's working out pretty well for me
where I can sort of have both corporate
and and non-profit passion work and and
I feel pretty balanced yeah and that's
I'm refreshing to hear the reality too
even though it sounds like you know some
people question or give some pushback
but just know you know there's different
ways to kind of bring those passions and
vocations together so that's encouraging
to hear how you've done that in your own
life as well yeah that's been great I
mean you know you don't have to I think
you know you don't have to necessarily
try to make your non-profit or this
fashion thing a full-time job if you can
you should but quite often it's a little
bit challenging in terms of the
economics they can come the compensation
and so forth
um you can still do it you can still do
it and do it and do it well
um and and maintain at least that's what
I've shown I've been able to sort of do
in my life and I really like that
balance although I've talked to people
who you know who kind of feel like well
hey you know if I could I would do this
full time and but it doesn't quite work
out in terms of you know you know pay
the bills and I'm like yeah this one
just kind of have two yeah you got two
hands right you're balancing a lot
yourself right I'm juggling a lot I
don't know if I've gotten balanced yet I
mean it kind of I would say Ebbs and
flows and people often ask me that so it
kind of just depends on like even
certain time periods of the year like
whether you know the research is really
the heavy emphasis whether you know some
of the diversity Equity inclusion Works
have an emphasis whether the podcast
public facing right so there's some
flexibility that comes there too but
like you it just is like at this point
in time it seems like it's the most
effective way to do things with so many
different teams working in different
entities but yeah yeah absolutely and
it's definitely a learning process
not balancing it's juggling I think
you're right yeah right about that good
call one question that I didn't
anticipate or I would imagine some
people might be thinking you know people
who are maybe trying to think about
non-profit versus something in the
private sector and academic sectors
and listening to you talk about how
you're doing both do you ever feel like
you have to sacrifice one or the other
yeah well that's a that's a good
question
um
yeah I mean at times you know the
demands are are they're not always the
same so there are times I think where
I'm I I have to work a little bit more
um especially with the nonprofit because
it's a volunteer thing I don't get paid
for that so it's all just driven it's
belief in that the belief that a
happiness cause that that mental health
should be accessible to everyone and
what they did to despite your race your
ability to pay income you know whatever
identifiers you have
um uh but so there are times I think I
have to sort of work a little harder to
kind of stay energized and keep keep
things moving uh with our organization
the work is the work you know you got to
pay the bills so you can switch off on
that as much at all
um and um but uh I think there are
certainly times where it seems like you
have to put a little bit more than I
would want to
um to to keep our the work going with
the nonprofit yeah that's I mean I think
that's a health healthy and helpful
perspective too you know for those who
may also be trying to think about that
or people who might be just finishing up
with school and try and think about
those next steps so definitely
appreciate you sharing that too yeah
and like I mentioned we'll definitely
lean into your life story as that's you
know a piece of your journey as well but
before we get there I did want to ask a
little bit about just your the
non-profit and how that came about how
that passion you know in a sense
developed yeah you know it's actually
it's hard with my story so I lived
through a support in Liberia so I you
know I think I mentioned you mentioned
my sort of the book like do your son um
which was a collateral collaboration
with a dear friend of mine David
berhagen uh David Hagin um telling that
story uh but but living to the Civil War
when I came to the U.S
um in 1991 I didn't know as I sort of
started going to school I found myself
really fascinated by behavior and sort
of why we why why why I did the things I
did and I'm not sure like how many 15 16
year olds walking around sort of asking
this question why am I the way I am you
know what I mean why where they are
um but I I had that interest in that
sort of that Fascination
um and I and and that led me to studying
psychology in college and and then as I
saw are starting to learn more about
this idea of trauma and resilience and
all those things that come with uh with
just sort of growing up and maturing
through to difficult circumstances I I
saw a lot of value in in in mental
health and in mentally emotional
Wellness so I um I I I kind of connected
with some folks who were who were
counselors and therapists in the area
and
um
a group of folks saw the Gap in Access
uh for for mental health care and they
decided to to start this organization
and uh and I knew some of those folks
and got involved through through sort of
the relationships we had and I've been
involved since 2015. and I think it
started it was launch officially and
then probably a few months ago I got
involved and I've been involved since
and it's just become something that I
truly value
um mental health is one of those things
I think you know that's better than me
and I do it's super important and but
yeah there's either low awareness or
there are just some hurdles that people
really engaging and seeing that as a
critical part of what uh I think Dr
Daniel Ayman calls whole body Health
rights through emotional mental and
physical
that's beautiful to hear it just I mean
the passion and the drive there I mean
obviously that definitely resonates with
me and I am impressed that you are
thinking about that as a 15 year old
yeah I don't know yeah mostly got hit on
the head
but it was just one of those things that
that's always been fascinating I still
see the world interested enough through
um sort of that little and emotional uh
Health lens you know
behaviors and and and understand sort of
root causes going below the water line
to see sort of what's at the base of the
of the iceberg as I like to say okay I
think I find that really interesting
yeah and that's so important and it
seems like you had I mean you're just
tying together things you were seeing in
other people's lives as you were here in
the US but then also perhaps even
reflecting black reflecting back on your
own experience absolutely and I was
wondering if you could just share with
our listeners as much as you want to
just your experience uh childhood
experience you know both before the
Civil War
um and after and even before we go there
I'll put in a little caveat
um you know as a son of immigrants as
well but as someone who grew up in the
U.S knowing that these aren't the things
that are taught in U.S history so
actually you can also give our listeners
just a little bit of context about the
history of Liberia and how oh yeah oh
man okay I know I'm throwing a lot out
yeah
I've been the US you know a lot longer
than I than I was in right two times but
as long as as I've been as I was in
Liberia but you know I still will I
still keep my librarian card
um anybody wants to question that but uh
but Liberia was founded by by basically
Freedom America Freed's life so freed
American slice so at some point
um after the Emancipation Proclamation
and you know there were people there
there are a bunch of folks who who made
the choice to go back to race settle in
Africa and they reached and and they
resettled in in West Africa and created
this country we know it's like beer the
capital cities Monrovia never was an
American official sort of colony but
very strong ties with um with uh with
with the us we speak English there and
uh it's not going to sound like English
you know if you see if you pull up if
you talked if I started talking my real
librarian accent or if you're talking to
a true librarian but we definitely speak
English we we
um like some of the values I think uh of
our countries is American as you can
imagine because the the former slice
brought those things there some of the
food some of the some of the the
dressing the the style and all those
things so strong ties uh with with the
US so
um outside of Liberia I think the most
liberians I would say are in in America
in the U.S uh childhood was was pretty
fun you know I had a girl with my mom my
brother and then we had a lot of some
family around so kind of a true Village
mentality every weekend seemed like it
was it was a family reunion you know
it's one of those things that in the in
here you have these family reunions that
are what once or twice a year because
everyone's still spread out every every
weekend I mean you know the the ants the
uncles the the the grandparents all came
and we just it was a just doing a
wonderful Village grew up with a lot of
love a lot of affection a lot of
validation a lot of affirmation
um in in in right outside the city
Monroe here went to uh a point to
private school and went to uh to one of
the better schools in Liberia so you
know my my mom really was big on
education and so that was something she
said she pushed and um and as you can
tell it it sort of stayed with us
um even till now so so you had a really
good life in Liberia I think I I
remember when I first moved to the U.S I
I really missed the life the pre-war
Liberia a lot you know it probably took
me a couple years to really start to
embrace all the opportunities and um and
all the the blessings of being in
America but uh you know things were
certainly different and not I've been
starting with the weather
um one of the things I remember really
sort of spooked me was seeing kids with
braces just like what that was just so
bizarre to me I thought you guys had
some aliens here or something like that
and uh so braces really freaked me out
but it was like life was really fun in
library I enjoy my life growing up and
really thankful for for the for the
family and the community we had and that
that love and that support
um that I grew up with I think really
became sort of fuel for a lot of the
other the things that would come come on
later in my life I There's real value
and and you know in growing up with a
lot of love and support and validation
and affirmation I think that gives you
confidence you know a dad I saw that
somebody you know there are a lot of
things I want to give my kids but but
but just sort of those those those those
those those those things I mentioned
with love and affirmation and validation
and I mean those those are definitely
the core things I want to give to my
kids you know because you can teach them
how to make money how to do a lot of
things
but I think those those foundational
things are really ultimately I think
what makes the big you know big
difference in my opinion and that's
really just my opinion of course yeah no
that speaks volumes as well and I think
it's so healthy for people to hear about
won the history because it's not taught
enough and just about the family and
community structure that you had there
um and in some ways you know I know
you've gone to this in your book as you
talk about all the experiences of the
Civil War from you know not really
realizing how serious things were to the
realities that hit at other points even
as you're talking just now it makes me
think about you know people like to talk
about resilience and you know where that
comes from and whether it's biological
but even as you were talking just
thinking about the structure and the
support system that you have from an
early age like that that is just like I
can just hear it in your voice in your
comments about how important that was
and it makes me wonder how what role
that actually played in your in your
story overall as well yeah you know
since I got more involved with with uh
sort of with understanding mental health
and especially with with trauma
um because we lived through some pretty
difficult things and there was an
interview I did uh with another on
another um show where the the person
and this was somebody I knew and and and
she said you know
we never saw any sort of weird things
about you you guys you know being some
being guys you know being kids who had
grown up in the war there was nothing
weird you know where we thought huh
those guys are clean you know they've
been shaped somehow but it's crazy about
this traumatic experience or you know
because we just and I think that was
because of this we didn't go through
this alone we you know we've been my
brother Jerry and I we we had so we had
this this community around us and I
think that uh before there were
therapists and and and and and and you
know all these different tools and
resources we have now around mental
health people were going through
difficult things and surviving based on
their faith and their Community right
and and I think that as I look back I
realized oh yeah we had those things
that's why I can you know you know I'll
be happy to take any test but I've taken
a few tests to say I'm pretty okay you
know they're not local you know not that
crazy or anything you know kind of a
normal person and uh but uh no no no no
no sort of you know sort of outsized
behaviors one way or the other that I
that at least that I've been told of or
anything but that community and that I
mentioned was a big part of it and so
apparently that's a maybe you know this
better than I do but that sort of strong
face strong faith community strong
um sort of supportive Community makes a
huge difference uh in how people weather
different storms in life yeah that's
definitely true and it's it's
encouraging you hear you share that from
a real life experience too I mean you
know the evidence definitely points to
that when people are looking at things
um socially in terms of things that have
happened in certain communities that you
know the both in terms of negative uh
impacts it can have on that Community
but how the community bonding together
can actually help navigate through that
and then going all the way back to the
biology as well I mean even you know
studies that which I've shared before
that people have done in rodents looking
at rats and mice if they're in community
and they're going through things
together how they'll show empathy
towards one another is how some of the
biology is involved in that people talk
about oxytocin being one of those
molecules that's important for that and
how that helps the map stream navigate
through so I mean you can see that all
the way from the basic biology all the
way up to the clinical literature and
some of the community-based literature
so it definitely makes an impact fact
and even as we're talking about faith
communities as well just even that first
pass again a little bit agile but so
many different stories of just the
importance of having people to talk with
or experience those things with and
listen to just like that first pass not
even if people are maybe not even having
quote-unquote counseling certified
counseling or social worker or therapy
but just that first step of listening
and walking through like there's so many
so many examples and evidence how
important that can be to help people
navigate through really learning that
more and more and I think over the years
so you know talking to guys to folks
like you and learning working with a
non-profit I think I'm getting what I'll
call the language to process the things
we you know we experience and the things
we had in our in in those sort of living
through a civil war
and how would you I mean how would you
say that's in your attention that's all
right but how is that informing your
work with psychology for all even now I
mean your own experience and what you've
seen the strength of the community how
it's helped you through how's that
inform what you do yeah going forward
yeah I know I think it's really given me
a passion you know for it now as I've
gotten a little older when I first
started doing this I think it was more
of a it seems interesting I have an
interest in it doing this being um sort
of being involved with the non-profit
with psychology for all it was it was it
was an interest it was
um
something that that's that sort of made
sense something that it was a good thing
to do but now as I sort of reflect on my
story and and my journey it's become
more of a it's kind of more of a passion
and more of a and I use the word other
Ministry where I think it's uh you know
in the Faith Circle you talk about sort
of Brokenness and I see this this
opportunity you know
um to be part of of bringing healthy you
know change to to some to some some
things some things you know you know we
might call you know some broken errors
in our community you know in in our
lives and uh
um all the books I've read all the
therapy and everything I've been through
um I always like to say this I started I
was started with I was patient zero
whatever that wasn't about try to fix
anybody else or change any lives it was
more about okay I want to make sure that
I'm healthy that I'm bringing my best
especially as a dad and everything like
that and uh and and then now I realize
okay because I see the benefits you know
I'm going to be part of at least making
folks aware of it obviously everyone
chooses what they want to do so yeah
yeah but it's definitely my stories
become an integral part of of of the the
my Approach and sort of what shapes the
lens through which I see the work we do
with psychology for all that's great
that's so important also I'm curious
because I know that you know some may be
listening and are feeling really
encouraged from hearing your story and
about the strength of the community and
some of the resilience but others may
also be thinking okay well I know people
who also went through difficult
situations and maybe had that Community
they didn't seem things still seem to be
difficult for them or someone who went
through a traumatic experience and
didn't have a good strong Community or
felt isolated and so how even knowing
your own experience and what you've done
so far what would you say to someone
like that in terms of some of the access
and mental health advocacy work that you
do
yeah I think I think that they're you
know your community is is really I mean
you get to kind of you can't there's a
lot of ways you can create your
community quite often you think well my
it's my family and the people sort of
within my neighborhood of my ZIP code or
if you're you know if you're living
somewhere you know in certain places
your village your town or whatever but
what what community is is is really more
you know for me I think the people sort
of have the shared values who who who
are going to sort of walk alongside you
right and support you and so if your
community as sort of as it as it looks
like right now is um isn't offering the
support
um you need uh yeah definitely I would
you know I would say expand your
committee one of the things that
I I had grown up and you may be familiar
with this you know just just a lot of
mentors and and I had I used to say I
joke as I had multiple mamas so
different you know these some of your
mom's friends or older women who just
were like disorder Tokyo and as the
Esther song or something they were
supportive or mentors you know
um who became part of that Community uh
and and and and provided some of that
support and that affirmation that
accountability and all the things I
needed so my my comment to those folks
would be get you to sort of expand your
community a little bit and go beyond
sort of the compounds of what your your
community looks like now and and find
those people you know who who can be
sort of the supportive folks and and
they're out there they are out there
there are plenty of obviously there are
organizations out there that are that
are that are that are that have mentors
and and they're providing and provide
mentoring services and other things and
then but what is a church a club uh
um you know YMCA uh uh you know
different Affinity groups a hobby you
know there's so many different places
now to find supportive Community I I
think and but I don't know well
that makes sense to you as a
professional capacity yeah I mean I
think that's really those are really
wise words too especially as you define
it early on if that's not happening
within the community people have a right
to be able to and be willing to look
elsewhere and to be able to get that
support of people who have that like
that like mindset so I think that's
really really important that you've
shared that and really really helpful
advice also curious because I know
you've mentioned faith and Faith
communities as well
um a few times so how is that what's
that aspect of your journey what does
that look like and how's that continue
to play a role yeah wow um
so
I don't know if we could have survived
the the the Civil War Liberia and we
live through some pretty you know pretty
scary things
um for a period of time there in terms
of just uh escaping fire fights being
held at gunpoint uh at gunpoint excuse
me a few times dealing with some with
starvation and food shortages
um I mean there are a lot of scary
things but we always we we always had
our faith and our and and God and just
in prayer and and you know I've come to
find that the the the the Bible is
probably one of the best if not the best
book of mental health actually you know
uh and this is uh I don't know too many
people agree with that but as you sort
of read the Bible and really get to know
the stories and you think about the
trauma that that uh Daniel and Charlie
and then ago or David or Joseph I mean
people went through some really chat of
course he chooses himself of course it's
really difficult things and and you see
how those difficult things the Arc of
those things led to to Victory you know
what a possibly or or or why they were
still alive and uh I thought uh and so
those things became
sort of part of of our of how we we
lived our lives and um yeah it's a big
part of faith is it's almost like I
can't see my life without my faith in
God I really can't I may not be you know
as I always say to my mom uh she
probably doesn't like me so I said I may
not be the best Christian right to be
honest with myself but but I do believe
and um and it's and and my whatever
little faith I had I have I think
continues to make just a huge difference
in how I I Navigate the the ups and
downs and the abuse of life for sure
yeah that's really powerful I mean I
appreciate even the way that you just
frame that even how you you know read
through the narratives in the Bible the
mental health Arc that's there that I
don't think we always give as much
acknowledgment or credit to as we should
about how difficult a lot of those
circumstances were so that's really yeah
they seem like stories but they're
they're real and I and you try to find
yourself in those stories you realize oh
yeah okay yeah you can sort of go
through the same process and and come on
the other side and be resilient and and
be a Victor uh and and so forth yeah
yeah really powerful and so many aspects
of community within those stories as
well even as you were talking about in
your own experience I mean there's so
many parallels there and things that we
can definitely learn along the way
um and to push on that a little bit I
know you talked about your faith in God
and just reading through those stories
that you know the practice of prayer how
is the Community of Faith has that also
been part of the the journey as well
yeah it's definitely yeah and as I
mentioned in in Liberia we had you know
we that we when we were living through
the war and well prior to that we we
were part of a church and you know we
used to host a Bible study at our home
and so we had that community and you
know and then an evening when we lived
through the war we still had that Faith
Community for our people we could read
the Bible with and um and pray with and
and even just talk through sort of the
experiences we're having and encourage
one another you know and that that okay
you know what
God God God can see us through this and
uh we're just going to continue to trust
them obviously you know
um some people made it and some people
didn't make it and you know then and put
you know why how why those that happen
that way you know I don't know but we
certainly um our fake Community really
was important and it was kind of a
perfect uh and then I'll call it therapy
or whatever but uh to help us navigate
uh what was a very difficult time and
that's become really true even through
now and you know there are I've had
other challenges in my life well this
health or family and and I've been able
to best face communities always been
there to kind of give me
um the strength uh to to see my to see
my wealth my way through whatever the
obstacles were yeah again just so
powerful and and sober at the same time
I know you know depending on when we're
talking where we're talking about faith
either here in the US or different parts
of the world it can look very different
in different situations and knowing that
in some situations
people are navigating through a whole
host of challenges that sometimes some
of us in the states can't even relate to
uh people who have had to um become
refugees or take a sound because of all
these things and to hear always to hear
stories of people holding on to their
faith in the midst of those challenging
situations and even as you mentioned not
everybody made it but how that was such
a bedrock and a foundation I think
that's so powerful and something that I
hope we're paying more and more
attention to in general but then also
just in terms of how it affects our
lives how it affects our mental health
and so again it's just it's just um
powerful encouraging and sobering to
hear you kind of walk through those
those pieces of your story as well yeah
that's cool
so I'm going to Pivot a little bit
because I know and as you know we we
pull in a lot of topics on this podcast
and we're getting to that already we've
already you know talked about some of
the uh the culture and mental health and
Faith
um but in terms of race that was another
topic that I wanted to kind of talk
through as well yeah especially with
everything that's happened the last few
years but then also knowing that
conversations about race are different
different and overlapping in different
parts of the world so I'd be you know
just curious if you share with our
Learners listeners your perspective on
race and race relations both from the
context of Liberia and for those who are
listening uh smiling right now so I'm
sure he has a lot to share but both in
the context of Liberia
um and in the states and then you know
there's some comparisons we might jump
into later even you know for my own
experience I'll leave it there for now
yeah I don't do that too much
that's a pretty heavy heavy
I'm thinking the dunk this thing or am I
gonna barely get the room but uh you
know until
I will say that in Liberia you know we
had we had tribes which
um and uh and I know I don't think a lot
of people are familiar with that with
the idea of tribes but they're
essentially just you know subgroups
within the country Urban dialects and we
call them dialects or you know languages
and you may have to add a better context
and to to some other stuff here but I'm
just going to kind of explain the way
yeah I know it um and so
my family was from One Tribe and and you
know but we were all obviously you know
dark-skinned black people you know and
and and but we but there were people you
noticed there were sort of stereotypes
and differences based on on what tribes
it came from right uh and so I had a
tribal context and uh but then coming to
the U.S now you've got a skin color
racial context which is which is
different and I grew up when I came here
I sort of grew up in a very a
predominantly white world and uh a
friend of mine who was jokingly said
that I was white socialized like yeah I
guess okay you know but but you know for
going to a prep school
um
prep college and other schools there
where you know there were not a lot of
not a lot of black and brown people and
and really enjoy those experiences
actually love those experiences and and
the values they sort of inculcated me
with and and and and and you know and so
I have no regrets but it was not until
college that I really started to
understand myself as that I started to
explore myself as a black man in America
and what that really
um so and uh that was a that was an
interesting experience so I started to
take I took some African-American lit
classes and didn't read as wild Allison
and daredell and you know the wall and
all these different and and then you
know some some uh some Cornell West and
and Skip ahead of those dates I mean
like that's when I read that that was it
was that was fun 19 years old then
um well then when I started to kind of
go through this after the
self-actualization of oh I'm a black man
in America that's different from being a
you know a black man Africa
and learning that and then trying to
sort of embrace that and still be true
to you know you know the fact that I I I
grew up in in you know what people make
I mean I call it American but people
might call the white world and I was
very comfortable in that space and I
still am and then there's this Liberian
part of me uh that I that I value that
and you know and I don't want to lose
either and so and then there's the
African-American side of me so I I never
I had to kind of realize I'm a
multicultural person I've never even
yeah right like my goodness okay I'm a
multicultural person so my view on race
is is it matters you know kind of going
from Cornell's Corner whereas book Race
Matters I think was one of the first
books I read on race and it is important
and um and I and I think there are some
beautiful you know sort of distinctions
that I think makes us as a community
better it's uh it is hard for me to sort
of uh
to kind of understand the the the
conflicts that we still see here you
know racially in America it's it's
something that I that I don't know how
much of it I you know is is
it's more kind of the lenses through
which we see the world and how much of
it is the reality of the world you know
what I mean
I I was a quote I saw not too long ago I
think from the talmud and it said we see
the world we see things not not as they
are but as we are and this idea of okay
what's what is it that I'm projecting to
to to sort of what's happened around me
and then what is it that's actually true
in terms of my actual experience of of
racism uh or or discrimination or
industry inequity you know so
um and if I answer your question that's
my perspective it's a it's it's
something I I'm growing into uh more and
more and to understanding and then and
then hopefully
um navigate in a healthy way yeah that's
so important I mean that quote that you
mentioned too and again I just it just
ties everything together because I'm
thinking about that both from you know
culture and race in terms of what we
perceive versus what is and how we don't
at least you know maybe perhaps just in
the circles where I am and we don't have
that conversation necessarily about race
as much but we definitely have that
conversation when it comes to mental
health I mean in a sense that's at the
Crux of some of the things that we talk
about when we're talking about things
like depression what do you perceive and
how is that different from the reality
of the situation and what state you're
in at that time but there's such an
overlap there and I think you know if as
much as we'd be able to have that
conversation within the cultural context
too and then to be able to question what
we perceive would actually allow us to
move to a better place of understanding
and healing yes yes absolutely easier
said than done obviously well but you
know yes that you're absolutely right
and thankfully you know I think um we
there's more there's more work being
done you know I think I think uh there
are more conversations I I would say you
know being being sort of being you know
had I guess
um and um and and so my general sense is
there that they're the chains are you
know in terms of like a football analogy
we're moving the chains but you know I
think maybe some people will probably
say no we're not you know you know and
they'll have their reasons why they
think that I'll have my reasons why I
think that too like why I think what I
think right yeah yeah but uh yeah how is
that tying because I'm also just
thinking about your non-profit too and
in terms of access how does that
perception versus real the one tie in to
whether people have access or not to I
guess whether they take advantage of
that excess and then yeah three once
they get there if the perception of them
is actually accurate because there's you
know there's a whole host of evidence
that people from black and brown
communities are put into certain mental
health categories or diagnoses much more
often whether that's correct or not so
yeah yeah man three-part question like
this is what let's go let's go one at a
time
I gotta slow down on the academic uh
mode keep throwing everything in at once
I think that that you know in terms of
of access you know I do I I believe
there's there's there are opportunities
there for us to to to drive more access
of
um uh with mental health or especially
because a lot of folks you know the
folks we serve I mean the average income
is ten thousand dollars you know and we
so you know that there's there's you
can't I mean therapy is really not cheap
I mean in my experience and
driving accessibility and you know to
the for those folks it's important
um I think the perception that may be
folks don't you know starting black and
brown communities I think you know don't
necessarily want to be a part of this
and and take advantage of this this of
these Services I I found it's not
exactly true right
um you know initially I mean I've heard
there's I mean I've you know seen
different presentations and read some
things about stigma and cultural biases
and so forth
um we're saying
um we're seeing in our in our data as
for you know year over year increasing
increasing utilization of our service as
people are aware of them and um and I
think and I think that that was sort of
a perception versus reality right well
yeah people just they don't they don't
want it they know people don't want to
take advantage of the services they
don't feel like they're needed they've
got you know whatever beliefs they they
have and whatever communities that
happens but no people people want to to
be healthier and I think maybe the
pandemic was a catalyst I don't know if
there's uh I know there's a connection
between you know the impact between uh
sort of the pandemic and mental health I
don't know if the I want to say and
maybe you might know this more
empirically that there was a there's a
connection between the pandemic and and
people seeking mental health care I
don't know that I probably something to
look into maybe it seems that way just
from talking to those who are getting
giving Clinical Services in terms of the
number of requests that they're okay
I've definitely had those conversations
with love yeah yeah I mean so we yeah I
mean like we saw that we saw that with
our with some of our data um but a bit
of axis is an issue equity in terms of I
saw an image once where a had three
people at three different heights
basically standing on the same kind of
stool or whatever and it was like well
that's that's you know that's sort of
equality but then it had and they were
trying to look up our fence at something
at the ball game have you seen this
before and there's one where yeah but
then you see the next image where it's
more Equity where it's like okay we're
gonna sort of adjust these things so
that everybody can actually see it
because even though we're all the same
place I got an advantage because my I'm
six feet tall and the other person I
wore yeah that was really interesting
because um it was a great visual on how
to think about this idea of equity which
which I you know which we we still have
a lot of opportunity to drive in our
community uh and I'm talking about
actually broadly across the country but
certainly where I where I am here
outside of Charlotte
um and and so that's another opportunity
and and I think the perception is that
just because we you know there's a sort
of what seems like an even playing field
everything that that's Equitable well
it's not right you know that's something
that I'm learning too so you know in the
reality it's not and trying to be part
of myself that so hopefully I hit all
three parts of your question there yeah
well I think you know you got the first
two the third one which I threw in the
curveball at the end was just and that's
too many at once go ahead just in terms
of um
so I mean in terms of how people are
assessed or diagnosed oh yes and we're
so where I mean that's a complicated
issue in and of itself I acknowledge
that I'm just curious any
you know yeah insights and perspectives
you have there
well let me say this uh uh I think
everybody knee is is a professor mental
health guy I am more of a guy who just
finds us more about something I'm
interested and I've read a few books and
I just have a sort of a raw passion for
it so I'm not I'm not a clinician or
anything like that I just want to put
that out there um so anything Lee says
you probably want to listen to it not
too much but we're gonna put them
together yeah put them together there
you go perfect good team player uh you
know
it I have heard and I've seen um that uh
you know we have sort of this book this
proportional rates of of you know
especially our kids being you know
has happened more or less well more
problems
um that that that is unfortunate because
I think some of that if it's done if
it's not done correctly I think shapes
the the individual uh long term right
you know and I think and I think what
I've learned is that uh those those
categorizations
do have you know long-term implications
and and can imprint can almost affect
the trajectory of your life in my sort
of my my small you know sort of space
that I operate in here and I've read a
few things like that and I'm sure you
probably can speak to this a little bit
more yeah I think that's a 100 on and
just you know from a scientific lens
even though that's not something I've
studied but have definitely read about
just in terms of developmentally how
important
those lists for lack of by the word say
labels at an early age can actually
impact expectations and trajectory again
think from a neuroscience perspective so
I think yeah I think you're exactly
right and it's so important that we
actually one pay attention to it and
actually you know do things to make sure
that we don't
put those things there initially but
then that gets into all the
complications about the biases that are
in the system or in our own minds as
people and how we do that without even
acknowledging in some cases realizing
some cases not realizing what impact
that can have
um on the upcoming generation and I say
that knowing that my age is increasing
as folks seem to be younger but it's
just so important I mean more and more
each day I think about the impact of you
know my own choices or words whether
it's with my own kids or kids in the
community or schools that I'm talking to
your college students and how much that
that can not that it's just on me but
each of us who have those roles can
actually set trajectory so yeah yeah I
mean yeah labels you know I mentioned
Race Matters you know Corner was this
book early uh and now I'm thinking of
maybe a label labels matter
and they really can and I I think
fortunately you know going back to my
story you know there the I had the
really healthy labels put on me you know
you know smart kind you know uh affable
you know those kind of things and uh
loving and and and and loved and all
those things and I think and it's that
that shaped you know again where I where
I am and the trajectory of my life and
uh as as we're talking out I realized
that I can think of people who have
different labels
um you know stubborn difficulty pain in
the rear you know you know and stuff
like that and and you'd be surprised how
people sort of internalize those things
consciously right it is so yeah yeah
that is a thing and and in our work
you know we we have some some in terms
of what the non-profit just creating
um trying to you know making sure that
we're working with therapy so therapists
who are credible and licensed and you
know some understanding some of the the
nuances of the community we work with we
try to have good representation of
people
um whether it's bilingual or certain
ethnicity and so forth
yeah yeah I think that's so powerful in
a lot of ways and it's again I know I
said encouraging about 10 times in this
conversation but just to to hear the way
that you're paying attention to so many
different aspects I mean both you know
hearing people's stories bringing in the
mental health experts also paying
attention to culture and background and
access aspects of Faith so I mean it's
just it's just I think it's powerful and
something that I hope will be replicated
in other ways as well I don't know if
that's something if you've been talking
to others in other communities or if
there's some long-term plans to see this
in other places in the country but
anything you'd be willing to share yeah
I would I think I think you know and I
know that one of the things that's great
about the mental health space is that
the need is so great so there and also
and there are plenty of and there's
there aren't enough I don't think we
have enough resources and then even
where there are enough there are ample
resources there's still a lot of
opportunity for us to sort of to be more
interconnected I think that from what
I've seen here and and sort of in where
we live the the there's a there the
people or the organizations are trying
to tackle mental health especially in
underserved communities it still seem to
be operating silos you know and so
um there there's there's an opportunity
to to try a better connection which I
think which will ultimately lead to more
efficiency better care delivery and then
ultimately you know a better
um better sort of service to the people
we're trying to to to help
um I would love to see this uh
psychology for all or that the model
that we use where we we don't we don't
have
um therapists who are like employed by
us right we have a bunch of Independents
independent therapists who you know
choose to to partner with us and accept
our rate and then and then deliver those
services to to people who can't afford
it who would otherwise be willing for it
and we've got people who have rates of
you know 500 to people who rates are
like 120 but we pay our flat rate of 65
so uh and so we're not our clients get
to work with the I would say the best
it's not some folks who don't know what
they're about to say who don't know what
who don't know what they're doing but uh
they uh their opportunities and it would
be great to see we need more
organizations even more so yeah I think
we need more connectivity between
organizations in the mental health space
uh quite often I think there's we got a
lot of people doing a lot of things but
as a as a someone who might be looking
for therapy especially if I'm
underprivileged
I only you know I only know of maybe
what's in the in my you know in my
community or whoever comes to me but but
I would love to see your resource where
you can just go and look up you know
what you want by race ethnicity
specialty all these things pull it up
and it doesn't matter you know where
people are and be able to try to find
services to meet your needs based on you
know whatever your specific uh
you know I guess interest are yeah
that's huge I mean even as you're
talking you're giving me some some ideas
and thoughts so I'm gonna have to extend
this conversation in some ways and I
think there's actually Focus I'm going
to try and connect you with as well
because I think that would that would go
such a long way
um and it's so needed in so many
different ways are you seeing that from
your work that I don't know if I'm
allowed to ask you questions but I guess
you're good
you know because I see this and I talk
to other people here but I mean you do
you have an obviously or a pretty large
um sort of uh Network I mean are you
seeing some of that sort of The Silo
that's operating and sort of individual
swim Lanes versus whatever collaboration
I mean it happens across all of the
Spheres which I talked about in terms of
the work so I mean I'll just a little
bit but definitely within the academic
circles the silos definitely happen
between institutions they definitely
even happen within institutions as we're
thinking about things like diversity
Equity inclusion work things happening
inside those things happening in
parallel and so a lot of the work that
we've been doing in that role is trying
to just open up the conversation to have
more collaborative conversations but
it's definitely happening within the
mental health spaces well I mean it's a
challenge because there are so many
things that are happening in individual
communities that are good but then as
you mentioned someone might be in a
certain situation and not know where to
start so I do see things you know as
I've been in this work for the last few
years and different pockets and
different places of the country and
those things are effective but it
becomes a matter of how do you kind of
galvanize those resources so that it's
it's broader across the country and even
broader for I mean we talk talk about
you know things that are important for
those of underrepresented backgrounds or
black and brown community so seeing some
of the things like uh they're uh I'm
forgetting the name therapy for black
girls and some of the organizations but
seeing there's a lot there are a lot of
large organizations but also a lot of
small organizations could also benefit
from having those commutes and so
sometimes it becomes many of us
individually and this reinforces it kind
of sending those resources out to people
we know but we still need a way to have
that be more Global so again you've got
me yeah thinking in a lot of ways so
well yeah that's definitely something
that I have from as a business person
you know I mean you mentioned I went to
business school UNC and so I'm a you
know got an MBA and I am a business Guy
and
um and uh I I think just that's a that's
a that's an opportunity uh to figure out
how to bring
um to add a skill right because you know
skill the the all the different services
that are out there
um in a way that that allows us to
actually have greater impact actually
yeah yeah I think that's well said
because you know at the same time I'm
still thankful for the work that you're
doing that so many are doing in
different places but just like you put
it to have even greater impact and to be
able to collaborate across groups I
think is really really important and I
think you know even push that further
small groups and some of the large
organizations so I mean we've been
fortunate in a sense because you know
coming from a place like Yale sometimes
gives us access to some of those larger
groups that we can kind of push those
conversations in those places too to
talk about thinking about aspects of
cultural competency or incorporating
aspects of Faith even in the
questionnaires that someone's looking
for people from different Faith
backgrounds so that's been encouraging
to see but still still so much more that
needs to be done yeah well and it's and
it's what I call a good opportunity I
mean and I and I think that uh it's it's
a fun problem to be part of something
um because because they impact is so
significant I mean you know this better
than I do I mean when you when you
change one person's life in a family you
can also in the network effect of that
it's just it's it's hard to quantify
yeah um yeah so yeah really well said
well again thank you for all the work
you're doing any last thoughts you want
to leave the listeners with in terms of
um like what gives you hope on a
day-to-day basis or even things that you
can encourage them to pay attention to
going forward
yeah you know there's it seems like when
you turn on the news now
everything seems so I know I'll say
disparaging and uh and so what I do what
I try to do and I think and I would say
let's you know be proactive about about
finding the good news and find the good
things and they could be just it could
be some of the same places things like
for me just hanging out with my kids
it's like it's really fun I started
playing uh pickleball and which is oh
wow we're in America and just being
getting out and that's really fun but
but yeah you know people just be
intentional about about finding things
that sort of bring you Joy and uh and
put a smile on your face every day
because uh there's a lot you know that
that sort of mind to take to give you
the opposite feeling so yeah that really
well said really well said I'm sure
we'll take that to heart again Eugene I
just really appreciate you taking the
time especially I know you had to move
some things around and just to create
space so definitely appreciate you being
here all the words of wisdom that you
shared your honesty about and your
vulnerability about your journey and the
resilience and Community that's been
there I know listeners are going to
really be encouraged by this and
hopefully spurred to do some some good
work as well from hearing what you've
been doing thank you so much you know
I'm a big fan of yours I respect your
admire your story and uh just just
respect my friend and thank you what
you're doing
foreign
[Music]